vous pensez que la Saint-Valentin ça
veut dire quelque chose oui c'est une
belle fête c'est dommage si on a monté
parce que ça manquerait à tout le monde
et bien Saint-Valentin parce que c'est
le nom de ce village qui est presque
unique au monde et
parce que probablement autrefois il y
avait les reliques de Saint-Valentin
dans l'église et que on a dit qu'il a
été martyrisé et que sa mort
coïncidait avec
l'accouplement des oiseaux
elle court la maladie d'amour et c'est
aux élèves de l'école de Saint-Valentin
petit village de l'Indre Benny des dieux
et plus particulièrement des roses que
nous avons demandé de nous parler
d'amour
et toi tu en as déjà vu les amoureux
et tu penses que quand tu seras plus
grand tu seras amoureux toi aussi
tu les as déjà vu les amoureux quand ils
viennent à la fête
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des gens sont fiancés ou qu'ils sont
amoureux
et toi tu voudrais plus tard être
voilà la petite fille en rouge la colle
à Saint-Valentin qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire bah c'est une fête
alors toi c'est pareil à quoi tu les
reconnais les amoureux
et alors après la Saint-Valentin
qu'est-ce qu'ils font les amoureux
[Applaudissements]
tu vois qu'il se marie
et toi tu penses qu'un jour tu seras
amoureuse fiancé puis marié
de ces beaux jours alors quand on est
amoureux la Saint-Valentin qu'est-ce que
ça signifie
c'est pas grand chose c'est toute
l'année là Saint-Valentin
est-ce que vous vous allez fêter là
Saint-Valentin
et vous monsieur que ça représente pour
vous la Saint-Valentin pour moi ça
représente ça représente pas grand chose
que je savais à peine ce que c'était
avant qu'on me le dise et elle a mis
février les oiseaux ont pour l'habitude
de se faire la cour
et je pense que on a voulu associer les
oiseaux aux amoureux et puis au mois de
février c'est l'époque où l'on fait
aussi sa déclaration de revenus d'après
vous il y a une relation entre les deux
choses
en mettant un peu de vis oui
pour nos clients nous organisons une
soirée de Saint-Valentin tous les ans
c'est une réunion qui nous fait réunir
une centaine de personnes ces personnes
hommes et femmes mélangées ces personnes
viennent un buffet campagnard dans se
rencontrent et il y a une façon très
spéciale de se rencontrer parce qu'il y
a un contact humain qui se fait et il y
a un tilt qui se fait tout de suite
alors les gens se forment en couple et
puis
l'année dernière
l'année dernière si vous voulez quand la
soirée était terminée je me suis trouvée
avec au moins 15 couples sur une
soixantaine de personnes ce qui est bien
et de ces 15 couples il en est bien
sorti cinq mariages dans le temps
c'était bon maintenant on essaye de
sauver les meubles comme on peut dire
voyez la boutique on va l'ouvrir tout à
l'heure on fait de la confiserie tout ça
il y a le les collègues tous ceux qui
sont là mais enfin c'est moins que ce
que c'était toute la commune travaille
avec leur cœur c'est à dire tout le
monde travaille bénévolement pour
arriver à faire une fête qui soit celle
de tout un pays
qui font les fleurs des corps toutes les
maisons et c'est assez secret on le voit
que le dimanche matin
c'était normal que je perpétue cette
fête avec ce nom prestigieux puisqu'il
était le seul en France tout au moins
son fiancé donc à Saint-Valentin le jour
de la fête nous avons demandé aux
amoureux d'où il venait et pourquoi
surtout il venait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi je suis une mini créole ce matin
vous trouvez une signification vous avez
une raison de venir ici aujourd'hui bien
sûr
vous êtes connu ici vous pouvez nous
dire l'enquête circonstances si ce n'est
pas là
alors c'est presque un pèlerinage pour
vous
vous êtes marié depuis vous êtes encore
fiancé
pour Noël alors on se marie au mois de
juillet ça se trouvait juste dans la
bonne période pour ça on m'a dit on a
profité de l'occasion
flirt avec toi je ferai n'importe quoi
pour un flirt
avec toi
je serai prête à tout pour un simple
rendez-vous pour un fleuve
la fête de l'amour c'est aussi les
accroche-cœurs les accroches patients et
finalement les accroches souvenirs
[Musique]
des petits cœurs
ce sont des jeunes des plus âgés de tous
âges toutes les catégories les fiancés
en particulier
[Musique]
quand vous voyez les gens en face de
vous vous pensez qu'ils sont amoureux
lorsqu'ils achètent ces petits gadgets
certainement pas là il profiterait pas
de la Saint-Valentin pour venir non
et même si l'amour était éternel il a
besoin d'elle postal mais où vont mourir
les messages des roses
vous voulez
une grande amie aussi quelle célibataire
malgré tout j'envoie une petite carte
tous les sens pour lui faire plaisir
vous pensez que la Saint-Valentin ça
veut dire quelque chose oui c'est une
belle fête c'est dommage si on joue à
monter parce que ça manquerait à tout le
monde et vous même lorsque vous étiez
jeune on fêté la Saint-Valentin c'est à
dire vêtements je me rappelle d'avoir
dit seulement
marchand de bonbons de quelque chose
comme ça qui se mettait au milieu de la
au milieu du PEGI ce qu'on peut prendre
on dit on veut le pôle client mais ce
qu'on peut accrocher au client mais on
l'a toujours pris
un petit coup de menton et puis
quand on est majorette on se pose la
question est-ce que l'amour a la même
valeur bien sûr
et vous n'êtes pas trop trop agressé
quand vous sortez parce que c'est vrai
que le voir des beaux hommes c'est
tentant pour les femmes bon ben je fais
un petit peu quoi vous n'avez pas de
problème à la maison quand vous rentrez
un petit peu vous faites des envieux oui
ou non
c'est ce qu'on lit du moins l'amour
c'est aussi la poésie et la chanson
ça y est
au seuil de cette journée restez une
question grave les amoureux de la
Saint-Valentin réserve-t-il une chambre
à l'hôtel du village madame le Maire a
répondu
[Musique]
viens ça je vais vous dire une chose je
n'en sais rien je n'ai pas posé cette
question indiscrète
mais une caméra de télévision quand elle
veut s'amuser sourire et beaucoup plus
indiscrète qu'un maire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vraiment fait là c'est complet
impeccable
[Musique]